gérard collomb âgé de 34 ans est le plus
jeune élu socialiste de la région
professeur de lettres il enseigne dans
un lycée de lyon après avoir milité à
l'unef et à la convention des
institutions républicaines
il a adhéré au parti socialiste en 1971
candidat malheureux aux élections
législatives de 1973 dans la 9e
circonscription du rhône
il est élu conseiller municipal de lyon
en 1977
c'est après
les revenus et jean poperen une nouvelle
génération
militant politique de grande 40 ans qui
accèdent maintenant avec ses nouvelles
fonctions à une dimension politique
nationale mais que pour la suite des
événements
je pense que c'est un amant n'a ri
gérard collomb d'ailleurs comme de
nombreux nouveaux élus socialistes est
un enseignant et il est à souligner et
chasser complètement conforme à ce que
l'on observe au plan national qu'il ya
parmi les élus socialistes 14
enseignants sur 24
[Musique]